nearly 3/4 of American teenagers own
smartphones many are filled with social
media apps 31% are connected to friends
that they have not met in person and 32%
had been contacted online by a complete
stranger the district attorney of Blount
County Alabama has posted videos like
this one to highlight smartphone dangers
for children
pamela casey was also featured in the 48
hours episode killer apps pamela
welcomed to the table good morning so
how did the danger of these apps first
come to your attention well I was at
home one night and got a call from a
friend who said she was very upset her
daughter had been taken inappropriate
photographs and said that she found them
in a vault app which is like a
calculator but you put in a certain
passcode it took you to an a volt that
she had hidden all these photos that she
had been sharing and the mother said
you've got to tell everybody and I made
a video and that video went viral and so
as a result of that it's become my new
mission to educate parents says kids are
so much more well versed in this and
their parents you say the parents are
basically clueless when it comes to this
absolutely I mean I'm in law enforcement
and I'm a step behind every time I go
and speak to kids I found out about a
new app that didn't know about the day
before there will always be a new app
every day that's going to have the same
dangers so let's help educate parents
one of them of yellow yellow actually
and it's works their snapchat I call it
the tinder for teens if you've got
tinder for dating now you have tinder
for teens and snapchat only requires you
to be 12 plus or that's the way it's
rated but yet yellow that you get into
through snapchats supposed to be 17 plus
kids can go on there and meet people
that they don't know the problem is you
got to give them your location in order
to start meeting people and it matches
you up with various people you don't
know the people you're talking to
whether or not they're actually who they
say they are and what about lively and
lively is very any type of app that's
going to allow you to have video live at
any time can be very dangerous because
you don't know what your kids going to
see now do you monitor what your child
walk watches on TV yes
but are you monitoring what they're
watching live on their phone it's very
musically lively as parent company
raised a statement to us saying that
they strongly encourage parents to
review and adjust privacy settings a lot
of these apps do have parental
guidelines to those help
they don't Facebook has a rating of four
plus would you allow your four-year-old
child to get on Facebook what does that
mean Plus each app that goes through the
Apple Store gets a rating through the
company what's the highest rating
seventeen plus okay it means safe well
that means that that's what it's
supposed to you need to be seventeen but
there's nothing that keeps you or makes
you prove that you're 17 or older so you
have kids who are you know I'm supposed
to be on Facebook unless you're twelve
so four plus it refers to the age so
what's a parent to do well you set the
plug the settings in the iPhone a lot of
parents don't realize that you can
actually go into the iPhone and turn off
your child's ability to even download an
app you can turn off the camera and you
can turn off installing let me show you
you go into your settings you're then
going to go into your general button
you're going to click restrictions you
put in a code now this code is different
than the password you give your child
always know your kid's passwords okay
but this is different I can go in and
turn off my child's camera they no
longer have a camera I can go in and I
can turn off their ability to install I
don't in making decisions I can even
make decisions I can even say I'm not
going to let you have an app that's not
ready to non plus that's interests you
say that guy wants your kids good
information this morning yes really yes
yes Alabama oh yes